breaking news overnight from north korea
a report that the country has tested a
missile that could be fired from
submarines making it a far greater
threat to the united states south
korea's military says it detected the
launch and this is a developing story
our raimi inocencio is in hong kong
covering it for us remy this is a
concerning one good morning
absolutely and good morning experts are
saying this is arguably north korea's
most advanced show of military
capability ever since president biden
took office and south korea's military
has now been saying that that was
launched at least one missile was
launched off the coast of sinpo that's a
city on the east coast of north korea
and a hub for its submarine production
program and this all comes after the us
met with south korean officials in
washington
where they reaffirmed their intentions
to actually restart diplomacy with north
korea and for its denuclearization now
north korea had revealed two new
submarine launch ballistic missiles
otherwise known as slbms during military
parades this year as well as last year
but this one it appears to be the first
time the country has tested an slbm ever
since 2019.
it's also the latest in a string of
recent north korean weapons tests
including what the country claimed was a
developmental hypersonic weapon but
north korea isn't the only country here
in asia accused of testing advanced
weaponry right now a financial times
report claims china has successfully
launched its own hypersonic missile just
this past summer
on monday beijing responded to that
report saying it was not a missile but a
reusable space vehicle used in a routine
test to help lower the cost of space
travel now it's worth it to note that
the us and russia are also developing
their own hypersonic missile technology
but if that financial report is true
then it means it implies that china is
now taking the lead in the development
of hypersonic missile technology in this
global race gail
some public signs there thank you very
much remy